[Music]
put your windows down
put your windows down
yo put your windows down
put your windows down
put your windows down
you have your relationship registration
insurance
center street
a lot of moving around he tried to take
off yeah
open the door
you got to step out of the car
what i can't hear you
what's your name man
we know that we know this is it
if you don't step out of the car i'm
gonna break the window and get you out
of the car okay
you got one more warning okay stop
preaching behind the fucking seat okay
stop reaching
my phone why don't you just open the
door man
open the door part of the car
okay open the door
right here open the door
look at my phone right here
just open the door man i'm not going to
tell you again man
i don't care who you are right now i'm
telling you to step out of the car
wrong
step out of the car man you're gonna
make this more difficult than it got to
be i'm gonna break the window
open
he's trying to start the court
[Music]
get them out of the car get them out of
the car
[Music]
put your windows down
yo put your windows down
put your windows down
put your windows down
you have your license and registration
insurance
pennsylvania
he's looking for because he doesn't have
it
let's say he's looking for it because he
doesn't have it
moving around
yeah
have them step up yo
open the door
you gotta step out of the car
what
i can't hear you
what's your name man
okay we just need you to step out of the
car does it
if you don't step out of the car i'm
gonna break the window and get you out
of the car okay
you got one more warning okay stop
reaching behind the fucking seat
stop reaching
my phone
open the door i'm not going to tell you
again
open the door and step out of the car i
don't care who you are right now i'm
telling you to step out of the car
step out of the car man you're gonna
make this more difficult than i gotta be
i'm gonna
open the
yo open the door
you understand you're
he's trying to start the car he's trying
to start
keep your hands up
heads up
dispatch shots fired on center street
shot's fired
get him out of the car get him out of
the car stop running donate
511 dispatch
come on with 513
782-557 center street it's going to be
pennsylvania
one occupant go for it this time
is
[Music]
what
we're looking for you to get your
license
what
what's your name
if you don't step out of the car i'm
gonna break the window and get you out
of the car okay
you got one more warning okay stop
reaching behind the fucking seat
stop reaching
do not fucking reach again
watch his left hand watch his left hand
[Music]
open the door and step out of the car i
don't care who you are right now i'm
telling you to step out of the car
step out of the car
step out of the court
bro step out of the car you're gonna
make this more difficult
i'm gonna break the window
then open the window
open the door
open the door open the door
stop stop reaching bro
open the door i'm not going to tell you
again
open the door
you understand you're under arrest right
you understand you're under arrest all
right
open
watch his hands watch the watch and
watch it watch him
[Music]
holy
[Music]
dispatcher get us a code three and
everyone's out here and a supervisor
y'all gonna back up and secure the scene
yeah 10-4
step up
open the door you got to step out of the
car
what
i can't hear you
what's your name man
let me know that just needs to
if you don't step out of the car i'm
gonna break the window and get you out
of the car okay
you got one more warning okay stop
reaching behind the fucking seat
just open the door man i'm not gonna
step out of the car man
i'm gonna break the window
open the door and step out of the car i
don't care who you are right now i'm
telling you to step out of the car
step out of the car
step out of the court laughing at the
bait bro step out of the car
you're gonna make this more difficult
than it got to be i'm gonna break the
window
and open the window
open the door
open the door
arrest right you understand you're under
arrest right
open the door
you're under arrest
he's trying to start the court
[Music]
[Music]
get them out of the car get them out of
the car around their knees
put your car in parking park
back up
all right